[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you for coming by to listen
today's show is a real treat if you're
at all into like spirituality or
Consciousness this is the show for you
or even just like how to live your life
to achieve your highest timeline the
guest today is Sarah alcaldy she's a
Mystic spiritual teacher and author she
goes by The Alchemist on Instagram and
YouTube and she has incredible content
on the nature of this reality and how
the universal laws play into our
experience we just unpacked what reality
is timelines Dimensions
Duality purpose Dharma these are all big
topics that we dive into and it was just
such like a fluid conversation we just
kind of kept navigating and weaving
through all of these very interesting
topics oh yeah plant medicine that was
one of one that came up at the very
beginning and the role that that plays
the danger that can be within it but
also what it can show you I loved it
like these are like my jam these
episodes are just I just Feast on them
because people that have had
experiences and gain knowledge in
the areas of reality that are more
hidden or occult uh
I just want to pick their brain so
that's what I did today enjoy uh please
hit subscribe I really appreciate that
grateful for you loving this channel
listening to this channel the Bell is
for notifications when we have episodes
come out and uh gosh let me know some of
your stories in the comments I'd love to
hear if you've had mystical experiences
or what you think about the episode me
and technology is just I don't know it
doesn't compute is there some like
Universal reason why like someone like
me who loves spirituality and like
mystery schools and ancient like is
there some like
reason why technology doesn't agree with
me I just want an excuse is basically
what I'm looking for yeah because I
wanted an excuse so I found one
because I see all these esoteric Bros
who like love math and I'm like oh yeah
and like I suck at math no matter how
hard and I use that and I lump that in
with technology and here's why we're not
good with that we came in to kind of
section off that part so we could do
what we need to do and that stuff would
like interfere with it
yes that makes perfect sense and also
like here's another weird thing I don't
know if you get this but I'm really good
at guessing numbers like I can guess
distances time weights Heights like I
can guess things and when it comes to
numbers but when it comes to actually
like the math of it and like The Logical
side I I don't it's it's it's it's it's
not a part of me so I think maybe it's
strong intuition and strong sort of
psychic capabilities but totally weak
logical mathematical capabilities I
completely agree I've actually forgotten
like it's left my memory like half of
the stuff I learned to even get me to
where I am today
yeah you know another one that's weird
too is names I'm just like names are not
my thing either and sometimes I think
about it from more of a spiritual
perspective and think how names are just
they're not necessarily that meaningful
they just help us sort of identify and
like make communication a little bit
easier like oh I was talking to Sarah
um instead of having to go into the girl
who has long dark hair and whatever else
um and so I think like names just aren't
actually that important
I completely agree as soon as somebody
tells me their name it leaves and so I
started to assess that and I was like am
I like a narcissist like do I not
remember people's names and I was like
no I just know like I carry the
information through a very similar means
as you and names is very irrelevant to
that explain your process when you meet
someone what are you assessing what are
you picking up and what are you trying
to figure out
that last part's exactly true what I'm
trying to figure out is where they're
dialed into not because I'm gonna go
match them but also to be appropriate
and so a lot of my journey has even been
just making sure that there is a
connecting factor a a very relatable
factor and so that's what I do when I'm
like dialing in
God I I like I feel like I have like
you're my sister already because that's
when I meet people it took me a long
time but I realized that I was waiting
to see if there I didn't know this but I
was waiting to see if the what they were
portraying matched with their energy and
seeing how sort of accurate and truthful
it was and then of course like assessing
where I go next do I want to talk to
them even or do I you know where do I
where do I go with this situation do I
move to another person what do I ask
them do I put them on the spot I'm I'm
an Aries so I can be a little fiery so
sometimes I just like to like prove a
point
um and so or call them out
um so I I realized that about myself too
I'm just like trying to match up the
situations but I'm seeing if their
energy matches their words basically
yeah and also I'm assessing like
I really like to
catalyze people so a lot of the time
what I'm actually doing is just looking
for where I can help them develop do
they have to ask for help that's a funny
thing because if somebody starts talking
to me at a party for instance then that
was them asking
literally hello is an Ask yeah if
someone's following me on social media
if somebody came into my sphere in any
way then that's me saying oh okay the
universe I've even had conversations
that are like super far out there at a
restaurant and you know the people who
I'm talking to
might not be as comfortable simply
because of the environment we're in and
I'm like anyone who's at a corner who
overheard anything that they were
supposed to I I normally don't go too
much into origin but I don't I don't
know exactly where your spirituality or
where your awareness and your knowing
came from or or when or if you if you
learned it or if you somehow an
experience you had
um helped you remember I can binge on
your episodes on YouTube pretty deeply
because it's so clear and so so
confident and clear and tangible so how
did that all how did that all arrive for
you so what happened was I came in with
a strong knowing But like everyone else
you just get gas lit into the program
right and then my Catalyst had nothing
vaguely had to do with spirituality I
didn't even know that my path was
unraveling into a highly spiritual path
it was more so just I was very much in
activism like very I know for my channel
I'm talking a lot about like super
metaphysical Concepts and everything
from like the highest plane of
Consciousness that I can access
but it started from literally like me
going to protest a lot me being very
angry me working through a lot of
catharsis with everyday Injustice and ha
and pulling on that unraveling that
because I like to use Health as an
example because that's how I even became
curious about anything I was interested
in health I used to be a personal
trainer and I noticed that a lot of
different people whether they're sick
and that's how they get into spiritual
Awakenings or one way or another it has
to do with health because once you start
questioning hey why is this in my food
or hey did you know that this is in my
drinks and stuff once you pull on those
threads if you pull on those threads
they unravel very fast and they go like
it's like whoa whoa whoa what the heck
are GMOs you know and so for a long time
I was really in what I would call like
the Bare Bones of
what later was I understand the
preparation
you know higher Revelations of of a path
that was unfolding but yeah so I came
into things
I wouldn't say super mystical
but yet I was always drawn to esoterica
always
and so I started kind of going back and
forth in between things that like very
much every day mattered to our world
and yet at the same time things that
were so mystical so cryptic that it took
a lot of studying and research and going
back and forth with forums that I was
interactive with at the time
so I came from what you could call
mystery School Forums
[Music]
um and you know hermetics hermetic
initiations and then I don't know if
you're familiar with the fourth way
you're deaf yeah so there's just a lot
of different mystical information that I
was exposed to on your own or was it
just sort of like coming into your
reality through someone you trained or a
friend or were you seeking it out and
you kind of like resonated with it
I'd say both because the more that I was
seeking it out and you know like being a
part of like groups
um very much mirror to you anything that
you can find wrong like
which which I try not I try my best to
take what really helped me
and be kinder to people than my own path
at the same time
um
that doesn't always translate just
because I straight up came from
mysticism so what I'm learning as a
spiritual teacher and even with my
channel you might see this is I I'm
learning how to
be nicer in my deliveries because I came
from no chill we don't have like you
need to say this a certain way you need
to prepare me a certain way you need to
be nicer you need to be this or that so
for me I'm almost like what I consider
public relations
I'm like how do I take my journey my
knowledge knowledge base my gnosis
and then create a bridge from it so that
I'm able to make
the make Consciousness cool make it
understandable make you know like yeah
but at the same time I got that bite
because I came from mysticism and
there's no you don't dilute things you
you don't by saying I came from
mysticism you're saying that that's
where your teachings came from was like
mystery School teachings was groups that
were engaging in that kind of
um information or ritual you're saying
that's your sort of background to this
information is mysticism yes but I still
wouldn't have called all of that noses
gnosis is meaning that it's fully
digested
it's fully metabolized
it's a part of you
what when I developed that gnosis it was
actually through mystical medicine
experiences I got blown open my my
emergence into enlightenment
was not at all what I was expecting
well good I'm glad you're telling the
story because the next question I was
going to ask was did you have some kind
of initiation yes
please tell if you're willing yeah so a
part of what I feel my purpose is here
is to really help awaken the world into
God Consciousness or Oneness and what I
was specifically shown
literally through every part of my
energy field very much so the physical
body
Source if if Source gave you all of
sources information in your physical
body you'd blow up there's no you can't
you can't store that much information in
Your Capacity yep
I was given as much as that as would not
kill me
yep and and nothing less
so because of that I hear like nothing
less I about short-circuited yeah I
short circuited I literally short
circuit my meridians and so after that I
was like
in this weird wonky land which um I
understand now is actually initiations
um after Enlightenment because a lot of
times people think Enlightenment is this
like end deal and it's not as a matter
of fact Enlightenment can even be looked
at as a springboard it's like okay
you understand we're all one there's you
know like it's to for people who are
truly enlightened put it this way it's
not that big of a deal
it's kind of like
it's the standard it's like can you
define Enlightenment then yeah
Enlightenment is to understand that you
are the other person and the other
person is you your different expressions
of source
so you are the all but you are also an
ambassador of the Earl of the all so I'm
you know we were talking about names
earlier I'm Sarah yeah no after
Enlightenment I had to go
I'm Sarah how funny
you're like this this this fractal of
saurus is called Sarah yeah
I was like oh you know like I'm a human
I'm playing human right now right
so yeah there was a deep integration I'm
talking years and it could have it could
have integrated better it could have
integrated stronger had there been like
more just Baseline nutrition support
like physical things going on but yeah
that's one of the things I I tell a lot
to my clients or I when I'm at my events
and I speak to people about when they
have questions a lot of the times I try
to bring them back into like hey how are
you caring for the physical body because
it's going through a lot right now
um it's not just a metaphysical
Awakening that's happening like the body
needs to be supported through this or
else it can't even house that much
information in a congruent and clear way
I'm I'm curious and you can feel free to
answer whatever is comfortable for you
but you know I talk about it fairly
regularly on the show about and I ask a
lot of questions about plant medicine
and I feel like that's I think that's
what you alluded to so I I'm curious
what it was
um if you're if you're sure if you're
willing to share but I've found that you
know
there's gateways to other realities in a
sober sense and you can do that through
I mean shoot I had a transcendental
experience with a dog on the beach in
Mexico but um you could do that through
meditation and various different things
or you can kind of like
kind of more guarantee the door with
some plant medicines or at least like
make it highly probable I still think
that you when your guard is up and
you're and you're not able to surrender
it still makes those those portals and
those gateways to other realities still
very difficult to access
um but I've found so much
what feels like very occult information
within them
um and truly my deepest question is in
life is what is this reality because
when I know understand what this reality
is I know how to play the game tell me
more if you're willing like what kind of
ceremony was it and you know there's
also so much so much around ceremony
right now or about plant medicines with
so Simon and Ayahuasca and peyote and
various different
um various different medicines that I
think people need to know the the the
the gravity of them and
um you know if that was something that
interested in them it's good to know the
right way to go about it too
yeah so one thing that made me a perfect
match to the ceremony being a way for
source to kind of like touch me if you
will was the fact that I have a very
broad bandwidth meaning that
for instance just
one example is an esotericism Lucifer
for instance isn't such a bad guy he's
like a frenzied Force
he comes with divine revelation he's
revered hmm there's also a downside
obviously but that's like more carnalism
more Hedonism the way that this
character is portrayed in the
exoterogram in the mainstream is
completely off base it's linked with the
devil or Satan and all these things no
lucifarian energy is one that needs to
be harnessed you have to make sure that
you can harness it but it's one that
definitely is so revered in esotericism
because it's all about gnosis
so that one example of the fact that
I have very little fear around Concepts
where most people have a lot of blocks
and fears
is just one small example I could go on
and on but really of the fact that
the more we're able to understand
complexity
and the more we're able to hold nuance
and really like Worlds at the same time
we're able to be for lack of a better
term more useful when we're in ceremony
or when we're communing or whatever
because if we're looking for a true
Awakening we're
gonna have to embody that right and that
embodiment there's a huge gap between
the mental Awakening and the embodiment
Awakening
totally totally and so because of that
the embodiment Awakening Journey looks
like completely different than the
mental Awakening Journey so to answer
your question I was in ceremony at that
time with psilocybin
I had done that several times before and
the only thing I could think of that
made that time particularly
um ripe is the fact that I was with two
very high vibrating friends so I kind of
look at them as like antennas that I
didn't know I was getting myself into
yeah it broke me it was not even like it
was nothing that it was nothing wild
there was no dose that like I was super
like oh man you're doing a hero sing it
was just to me very standard I went in
with the intention to meet my ancestors
something that was pretty grounded for
me at the time I'm in my ancestors all
right so I lost my mind in this tent to
the point where I had PTSD
for months later where I'd wake up in
the middle of the night and think I'm
still in the tent so it became like the
tent for me
but it broke my mind and I all of a
sudden was processing all this
information about source
I wrote poetry about it
I could not ground worth anything and I
kept talking to the people who were in
the tent with me as though they were on
the same level of Consciousness with me
so we were a group Consciousness and I
kept looking at them and we were all
well I found out later they didn't know
that any of this was going on they just
saw that I you know I left were you
actually talking to him or were was your
perception that you were I was talking
to them okay but everything that I said
they took it from their level of reality
but I thought that they were at my level
of reality and they weren't
so I was processing source and Source
was showing me look this is not only who
you are this is what's going on and I
started getting a bunch of information
about what's going on and I'm like and
then I got a bunch of shame because of
all the wars taking place on Earth and I
was like oh my God because I'm God I was
like I'm so much drama oh I'm so much
and I got like complete shame for all of
the conflict that I started and then it
was telling me that like you have to
come here and do what you're gonna do
like you you have to come speak and
teach and I told the other two which I
thought we were all on the same page and
I told them why do I have to be the one
to take form and I was so mad and bitter
and I want I didn't want to be the one
to be informed I I wanted to be I guess
at the time one of them that relay
information to the one who takes form so
I felt like I got the short stick like
we all Drew and I was like and they
didn't know they were like what do you
need to go to the bathroom but for me I
was like reconciling something at a
higher plane of Consciousness so I was
turning to them and I was like I don't
want to be the one to take form and I
just felt like the whole Consciousness
funneled in and said Sarah will be your
name like does that make sense what did
reality seem like in that space
what was reality as you learned it yeah
I'd never I had never seen it that way
before it was all etheric it was all
like if I was looking at you right now
you would look like
almost translucent
everything looked completely translucent
and even
Source came in in a very like
cliche typical bible-ish way very
translucent light from yeah have you
ever seen the movie I believe it's
called The Nines with Ryan Reynolds
no okay so after I had that experience
later on I saw that I'm gonna watch it
now but yeah so you have to and then I
tripped out even more because that movie
was about I don't know if I should spoil
it for you but essentially it was very
similar to my experience and I was
already trying to integrate my
experience so once I saw that that to me
was like no you cannot when you
integrate it that does not mean you
cannot pretend that this wasn't real so
once I saw that movie I was like oh no
this is my new level of reality I have
to play at this level of reality so my
Enlightenment and I say that with no ego
because like I said Enlightenment to me
is not a big deal and I know that
there's a lot of
um
taboo around that word and I think that
that taboo is there for a good reason I
can see that's the problem now I can see
everyone's perception I can see why
people have you know um boundaries up
against that word and I think that those
boundaries for the most part the
overwhelming majority of the reason why
we have an aversion to Enlightenment is
because of you know really toxic
teachings that have been passed down
throughout the ages that with you know
like the typical Guru type however
Enlightenment is you know if there were
another name I'd just use that name
because to me I don't care about the
name so I'm using the name Enlightenment
because we can all kind of like agree
that when I'm saying that that it's
talking about a specific level of
reality
and so for me it just was years process
of integrating that new level of reality
and now it's just you know I'm more
grounded because I've done various
different medicines and I did see a lot
I did a hero's dose not too long ago
five grams of psilocybin and it it was
uh
it's quite an experience but um so I've
and and and I've done Ayahuasca and um
you know done ceremonies so some cool
stuff has come through but or even my
experience with the dog and this
mystical experience and this being able
to feel pure love and and that whole
story
um I look at it like
I go into the experience and my reality
on the inside matches the outside and
then when these things happen my reality
on the inside no longer matches the
outside and that I always tell people if
you're first off like plant medicine has
to call you it's got to be your decision
because number two like it will change
your life for sure like it just there's
just no getting around it and it's for
the better but it doesn't always feel
like that for a while because a lot of
things can change
um but what is that Pro what is
happening within that and if you agree
or maybe you can articulate it in a
different way but what is happening in
those ceremonies or those those times
when we have an experience that shows us
something we've never seen before and
changes our life like what is happening
in that process I look at it like
jumping timelines but I don't know if
I'm articulating that right there's
always an energy exchange so for any
um medicine a person takes
there's subconsciously an agreement that
I'm going to have a fast track I'm going
to have an accelerated experience
one that would have taken me a long time
to acquire but because we're in the
spirit of this age it's fine it really
is
you you push the button and then you
know like you we have to
um not like it not like in a very you
know anxious way but we're playing
catch-up to our spirit and our Spirits
are very huge
um
so but there's always an exchange so
what we're doing is going okay
I need to get to here
this will get me here quicker for
whatever means that is for the person's
Journey where there might be an issue
however is that the embodiment doesn't
actually happen the integration so
that's when people have a peak
experience
and those Peak experiences fade away
after I would not consider that
Enlightenment people are having Peak
experiences I don't care I don't lose
sleep at night over it but people are
having Peak experiences and then going
back to their level of consciousness
when you don't when it's what you said
where you have that and it changes you
what's going on is not just a bunch of
neuroplasticity
but
think of your circuits or meridians in
your body as like
freeways of information
you're reconfiguring all of that so that
you can hold more then you have the
current capacity coming into this world
with so what's going on at that level is
cellular reconfiguration because
degeneration is when cells start
um not communicating
so upgrades you know we love upgrades in
the spiritual Community yeah upgrades
are when cellular communication
strengthens because you could look at
that kind of like fiber optics
like you're so what's going on is a
reconfiguration to the meridians and to
the cellular body in order to strengthen
cellular communication
what could go wrong in those scenarios
like we were talking you know you open
up you're opening up portals like what
are the dangers of those experiences
because I think those are real and what
do you do to protect yourself yeah
they're very real I've known you know a
lot of really permanently crazy stories
but you know as with anything I've heard
just as many if not way more positive
ones the negative effects are that
possession
straight up possession when you're once
again it's an energy exchange so since
it's an energy exchange you're going
here like
uh I'm an energy healer as well the
energy field from what I've learned from
shamans to Alchemists
there's certain substances
that tear your field apart completely
tear it apart and not in a positive like
upgraded way like tear the field apart
and so because of that when the field
gets so distorted from certain
substances
not only is how you're calling it
portals
that's ripe for possession and that's
ripe for
um creating more fragmentation within
the being so
our our Consciousness is like muscles it
tears and it grows back stronger that's
the point but when it tears and it
doesn't grow back stronger it tears and
it becomes more fragmented so it's the
opposite of the integration that is the
biggest danger with the medicines talk
about the integration part of it then
the integration prior to it is back to I
always say this minerals like it's
really like truly like your physical
body yeah physical body support
like what's the difference between a
great experience in with medicines and a
very horrible one I don't know how much
vitamin C did you have
does your but like think about it how
much
how much do we put our liver through
just as one example how much do we put
our adrenals through
um if our vehicle
is running on empty
and then we go and we stimulate it we
like we like really stimulate it how are
are we setting the body up to like
really be able to have a substantial
integrated you know mystical experience
oh wow
so if the body like doesn't have enough
vitamin C just as one example
so the liver is like okay I was already
taxed and now I have to go process all
of this new stimuli it's not going to
make or break I don't want to make this
sound like I once again I don't lose
sleep over people having Peak
experiences and not integrating it but
it would help if people make sure that
they have you know like sufficient
nutrient levels is that where the diets
came from to prepare for ceremonies like
some people go straight into an eye
ceremony and they just like do it and
then like my experience was having redu
taking out animal animal Meats for any
animal products for at least a week to
you know not a lot of fatty fatty and
salty and sugary Foods just like really
getting Bland blend blend blend all the
way to ceremony and then having just you
know quite a specific Diet before
um is that where that comes from or is
that more just ritual
that's ritual so that would be my
Approach is more modern and it's a mixed
one because I I've studied under
different holistic means
so how I'm looking at it is resources
does the body have enough resources
what you're describing
is great
for attaining higher Revelations and
that's what that diet is specifically
meant for so yeah that's a great diet
for for the means for the mystical to be
able to get your body in a position to
process the medicine in a stronger way
yeah totally have not a lot of
interference keep reducing interference
with the medicine
absolutely because what you're doing is
making sure that the vessel
is in a detox or a more pure State yeah
so that's doing it's it's um detoxing
The Vessel what's the point of these
medicines were were they put here for us
to use or were are they just natural and
we just think it's kind of interesting
and it's so different like I I'm just
trying to understand like from a more
from a more macro level what are what
are they here for
yeah the the medicines are here to help
us remember when it's time to
I always say that I think that the whole
world should just whether they want to
or not
you know those like giant helicopters
just like DMT
well you know DMT when you're a baby and
that's why you're this pure little thing
and then
that's my force quit
said I go you no just DMT them all
so
much vape pens at least at least
yeah so for me I think that they're
definitely a tool and that's why I'm
okay with them being an energy exchange
I don't think this needs to be a huge
arduous process because
Evolution on its own if we were to leave
Evolution up to Simply
without help of these medicines
would take a really long time
but we also have the energies within
this age that are super supportive
regardless of whether we're taking
medicines or not the energies in this
age are different than the energies in
the hb4 and the hb4 so the energies that
we're swimming in right now are pretty
much DMT anyways like they're they're
just super Lucid I've known people who
have reached very similar States Of
Consciousness as the one that I was
explaining
through like an MCT brownie
and it's like how's that weed brownie
gonna make you blow up and it's not
because of that it has nothing like like
the MCT brownie is like the excuse
it's almost like the so I tell people
all the time like if you use the
medicines that's absolutely fine I'd be
a complete hypocrite to say you know
don't use those I don't use any anymore
but that's because I caught a lot on my
plate to integrate so I'm fine with that
I think they did their job
um
yeah but I feel like even with or
without them the spirit of this age it
just really enhances what we already
came in and our purpose in this lifetime
yeah have you heard of the stoned ape
Theory
no but I think I know what it is it's
basically that back in you know very
ancient times where you know humans
weren't humans they were
whatever homo homo erectus or whatever
phase Humanity was in but it was that
they basically were eating like
patty-sized
hallucinogenic mushrooms and it just
extend expanded their mind and evolved
humanity and in a really accelerated way
yeah that makes sense that totally makes
sense where did Alchemist come from like
why is that why was that the word you
chose for you know presenting yourself
where did where did that come from I
wouldn't you know I used to just think
when I was first learning about alchemy
that it's just you know like at the
Hermetic art and the Hermetic Arts
there's
um four classical hermetic Arts but I
just thought I have a way different
perception of El Camino I think
the cosmos is alchemy everything is
alchemy because Alchemy is also where
chemistry derived from you and me
speaking exactly on this day
um but yours and mine energy combined is
a certain Alchemy
and everything else like getting a
tattoo
is alchemy because you everything goes
in
to the tattoo once you open the skin
everything
the what the stars were doing at that
time the mood of the person who was
making the text everything so everything
you could go to this you could visit the
same country twice and you could have
completely different experiences and it
would be what was the context what
context were you there the first time
what context were you there the second
time
everything is alchemy because everything
depends
on us and so it's like we're never the
same person nobody crosses the waters
twice we're a different person each time
and because that's Alchemy and so where
I have gone with Alchemy versus where I
came from Alchemy
I'm teaching now Alchemy at what I
consider a far higher level
and because because Consciousness is
alchemy
so how when I first started off as The
Alchemist
it was definitely more on just the
esoteric Arts perception of alchemy
and now it's evolved to everything as
Alchemy this entire reality what is this
real what is it that um builds this
reality that we live in what what is the
fabric of our existence what is the
nature of this game like what what what
builds are what builds this reality
Consciousness Consciousness builds this
reality and it
we're in a specific Dimension that if we
were to be in another universe or
another dimension we wouldn't even have
the same laws for how we interact
but this universe has as you may know
the Hermetic principles I do so in this
specific universe
we interact through those principles I
don't even know what's going on in
Another Universe because I don't have
the hardware for it we come into this
universe specifically with the hardware
for this universe
because we can't house the other
information that'd be too much to focus
on much yeah and so what builds this
reality is consciousness but a
Consciousness that's focused into a
universe of light and so a universe of
light splits into the opposite of Light
which is light and Shadow and so the
basis of what's generating this universe
is experiences that require and are of
alchemy because Alchemy is using
that catalyst the that shadow yeah to
springboard
so everyone who can springboard off of
their trials and tribulations or their
you know darker points is an alchemist
but that's that's what builds this
reality it's the tension of those
opposites
so are we meant to um what are the word
that comes through is Duality are we are
we meant in this reality this time space
reality now to or I maybe I'll just say
being a human is it about Duality and is
it about the light and dark is that is
that fundamental to this experience as a
human well that never go away
it won't go away in a human form
but we can evolve into
a higher form of human
and in that there will still be a dance
it won't be as crass
so there's always going to be that play
of dark and light when we're in a
universe of dark and Light
but the levels of crass
don't always need to be there and so
we're we're in a a period of Revelations
where things aren't getting darker but
we're understanding what has been hidden
far stronger now
and this is is this how we then evolve
by shedding light on the darks that
feels like very much what's going on in
the world like where it's I don't think
it's worse than ever I think we're just
seeing more so it's more in your face
it's like it's obvious now so is that
how we transcend is to shine the light
on the dark
yeah so whether people believe that we
got a raw deal
we got tricked one because a lot of my
audience you know I speak to a white
audience and it's funny because a lot of
the times I'm speaking to people who I
was fully in complete resonance with
so yeah so sometimes
we could look at it like we got a raw
deal we had terms and conditions coming
into this reality that we're not honored
I don't believe that but that's a very
strong Viewpoint in the conscious
community and in some spiritual circles
and then another way of looking at that
is that we came into we opted into
maximum fragmentation so Earth at that
point would be like a lot of the
spiritual Community talks about the new
Earth yeah and that Earth is a master
class we can look at it kind of like
that like did you want to sign up for
like the haunted haunted house
so it's like yeah did you want this task
list or this task list right so it's
like maximum
fragmentation
and going into that
that doesn't mean we have to stay in
that experience you know there's an
Awakening happening but the human
condition as is if we were to not evolve
is one of choice we have more Choice
than any other density we're in this
place where our true nature and this is
going to sound very desolate but I don't
mean it in a desolate way our true
nature is we're programmable so we have
an inclination which we call Humanity
our humanity is towards empathy that
empathy can be redirected like like
we're given a certain set of conditions
but at the end of the day only our free
will will be able to really do something
strong with them because we're placed
with a bunch of different programs and
influences
so our true nature is one where yeah we
have Humanity but we're also super
programmable and so to become fully
aware of that we know that even our
empathy can be programmed
everything can be programmed so that's
why I teach so much about free will and
discernment because Free Will and
discernment will allow a person to
harness whatever their nature or their
humanity is in a really exalted way and
not in the programmable State a lot of
times I talk about two concepts and
it'll be like the dark oh but not that
dark this dark or the light no no not
that light this light and it's because
there's different qualities within even
the natures that we speak of and so
understanding will build more
discernment
and the more we understand and the more
we have discernment we'll be able to get
in touch with our true nature and that's
a that's beyond programming so we have
the lower nature which is we're
programmed that's that's the human
condition is we're programmable
but the higher nature the one that we
you know the one that will take our free
will to harness but is completely
accessible is the higher nature is
discernment which leads to Evolution you
mentioned Free Will and I have a lot of
curiosity around Free Will versus
determinism like did we come in with a
task and a mission and is there is this
predestined because I've done some I've
had some experiences not on medicine at
all it was actually an EMDR where I was
like wow this is soul orchestration I
can see there's like an oversoul or
um energies or guides that are literally
like turning my head at the right time
giving me an experience like this is
part of what I need to have happen to
um achieve what I came here to do and
then there's you know or is it just free
will like what how or is it is it a both
is it an and or an or or both first I'll
say the reason why that's happening to
you is because you're living in Dharma
what we want is to get everyone to live
in Dharma so that everyone get you know
so that's why I teach starting Dharma
and explain Dharma because I I mean it's
it's a powerful thing but maybe not
everyone knows a Dharma is when somebody
is living their purpose
so each of us have a nature and if we're
able to tap into that nature fully
understand it and then use it in the
highest capacity possible for that
nature
that's Dharma and in Dharma it's a
different it's literally
less Cosmic laws
govern Dharma then the lower levels so
you have let's say Baseline
Consciousness is one that in mysticism
is called somnabilistic but let's just
call it unconsciousness
so if the Baseline is unconsciousness
there's more Cosmic laws to govern them
so you could look at it like a hypnotic
State man is under stronger forces of
sleep he has less free will
so there's a stronger pull a gravity
towards sleep
the more a person starts to awaken
the more they hopefully are using that
Awakening to go wait a second I can
access more of my free will
the more free will they access they're
not changing their nature they're
understanding their nature and
understanding their nature plus
Awakening equals accessing their dharmic
path their purpose their you know what
um Campbell called Bliss
hmm
so so that realm is a different realm
than What's called the general law or
what I was talking about unconsciousness
and so
so that's why you're having those
experiences and then when people are are
in their Dharma
they may possibly think that everyone
might be in their Dharma and so a large
part of my purpose is I really would
like to help harness people's
discernment because that's what's going
to allow them to access more free will
create more sovereignty and maybe they
might hop on their dharmic timeline
explain how people can do that more if
somebody's like yeah I want to do that
what do they do first and foremost it
really depends on like I don't like
being linear at all but it depends on
how much capacity for truth a person can
have
because there are certain things that
are subjective and then there's certain
things that are not subjective at all
and so just like how you were saying
earlier like is this predetermined that
it's both it's you get random variables
called chaos and then you get ordered
which was predetermined and then you put
them in a little bag like two cats and
you watch them fight and see what
happens
and so there is always that Randomness
that comes out of that construction so
there's predestined mixed with what are
you going to do next
and so between those two is how we live
our life and so how a person can harness
enough of their free will to enter their
Dharma is by first understanding
that those two are in harmony with one
another
and
we could look at it as the subjective
and the objective having a higher
capacity for the objective meaning the
objective truth of the world is going to
allow a person to locate themselves in
like what's actually reality in this you
know because I know that there's a lot
of different ways that can be
interpreted like like what do you mean
by this reality but the consensus
reality
okay so understanding having a larger
capacity for truth will allow a person
to now go oh wait a second maybe that
wasn't my purpose maybe this is my
purpose so do you see how if we're not
located in truth we might think our
purpose is like oh man I'm supposed to
go
be an actor and acting school I got
nothing against acting I wanted to be an
actor that's why I'm using this as an
example
but if we're not located fully in truth
maybe that's not our purpose maybe
that's not our joy maybe that's and that
could be someone's and that could
totally be someone's Dharma one person's
Dharma might be acting in another
person's Dharma might not be acting at
all but a being won't know how to locate
themselves and what their actual dharmas
if they're not having a larger capacity
for truth does that make sense huh well
yes yes it does and you know as soon as
you said the word truth I
it's something that I seek very deeply I
I no matter what the pain I want to know
the truth because I know that it's
eventual
um I know that it will put me on my more
accurate path I know it will lead to
more joy more peace more more Evolution
more growth
um I think that's why I say yes to plant
medicine I say yes to it's just I'm I'm
ready for the truth I want to know it no
matter what it's probably why I move
fast in a lot of situations because it's
like let's just cut to the chase here
um so I think it's worth like spending a
minute unpacking what truth is
truth is
objective reality we have subjective
reality and objective reality
they're not in Conflict now I've come
from as we talked about earlier
mysticism and in some sectors of
mysticism
they worship objectivity
to the point where I had to kind of like
heal an accident aversion that I had to
subjectivity just because of how much
dominant objectivity is
so objectivity is considered truth
now there's subjective truths people
have and that's their personal
experience and then there's objective
truth meaning that
what out of all the potential available
energies there was one thing that
actually manifested
all the other ones we could call
subjective potential available
but the thing that became what is
the thing out of all of those variants
that went no but it could be something
simple like I opened a refrigerator door
I closed it that is the truth of that
action
if now somebody comes along and says she
opened the refrigerator door she put
food in there and then she closed it
that's not the truth
that's not what happened that's not what
is
so objectivity broken down to something
so simple as that like refrigerator
example is
what is what happened in the past and
what hap is happening now
that's truth
how about an example of there's a car
accident
there's four Witnesses
they all give their report after seeing
the accident of what happened and all
four have slightly different stories
like I'm very curious about whether
about objective realities and whether or
not they exist because we all have our
own personal lens of how we see things
so I'm really curious what really
creates an objective reality just like
you walking across the river you're not
the same and the river's not the same
you can't you can't do it twice the same
way you're not the same person it's not
the same experience so really what
creates an objective reality other than
our perception
who's percepting
so let's use your example of the
accident where there were four people
the objective
Viewpoint would be
the camera that was in the air
that was had it below the Observer the
oversoul the higher self yes yes so yeah
that would be the objective one and
that's not to say that that's battling
people's subcl people's you know
subjective reality
one of those people might have had a
very accurate perception more than the
other three people who were who were
reported
but that person let's call it the one
out of the four who had the most
accurate account could have been let's
now use this as a metaphor for
spirituality the one that was most in
alignment with the oversoul yeah right
less traumas less less
um less fractioning of their being
because of things that had happened that
made them see a situation different
because of too much karma too much too
many traumas that would distort
the truth which is the oversoul higher
self objective reality so it almost gets
back to a little bit of like our the
very beginning when it's like I'm trying
to see if their uh what their projecting
matches their frequency it's like how
much truth is here like can you be can
you hold
how how much how much [ __ ] do you
have
how's my coffee go I'm too magical for
your [ __ ] how much how much [ __ ]
is in the way of you being able to see
more of that objective reality truth
that the oversoul or higher self is
seeing in that way
exactly so in this case scenario it
would be the person who was closest to
the thing
so not all of the even their reporting
could have been equal
so yeah so so it's subjective reality I
do not want to negate that at all
because I came very much from schools of
complete negation of anything emotional
and subjective so the subjectivity of
our own personal experiences
are contributing to the consensus
reality
so they're not opposing forces at least
I don't perceive them as them I view it
as Harmony and I view it at a higher
level as the masculine and The Feminine
energies in a form of symbiosis whereas
with here it gets translated into a lot
of like conflict sure because it's
essentially the way I guess I'm seeing
it is that the oversoul it's like it's
you it's still you so it's just seeing
things from a different perspective
which I totally want to ask about
Dimension so don't let me forget
um but it's it's working with you and in
this guided process through this Human
Experience it's it's sort of right there
and I feel like part of my work that
I've been doing more deeply is getting
more in touch with that intuitive side
of me the the psychic intuitive
um and you know just part of me that is
like the quiet voice underneath that is
leading you through your life that most
of the time and for most people never
know is there
you're doing it
trying to do it
um okay let's talk about Dimensions I
get very fascinated with this and and
you know can you explain them and what
they are and how they play into our
reality and of course you know here we
are trying to shift into a new reality
of new Earth 5D so like what's what's
happening
yeah so the fifth dimensional
Consciousness is what needs to be
embodied first and for those of you that
are wondering what happened to 4D we're
in 40. we're already in 40 which is
the fourth dimension is one that well in
layman's terms it's mathematical every
time I talk about the fourth dimension
people go like it's math and stuff it's
like I know but it's just sexier to call
it the Matrix but the Matrix is
mathematical reconfigurations and we're
projected into that so the third and the
fourth you can kind of just look like
that could even be like a really cool
Tool song like the third and the fourth
like that's just like the third and the
fourth are like the same so The Fifth
Dimension is a fifth dimensional
consciousness of Oneness that
enlightened State I was talking about
and now not the gnarly fragmented parts
of that but the overall
symbiosis of us being the Creator and
the created not in a Creator way where
we're putting ourselves you know above
Spirit
um there's this even this dichotomy
going on in Consciousness in in the
spiritual Community where I see people
fighting a lot over like
we're the Creator or no were they
created and it's like bro like like I
calm down like like when you're in fifth
dimensional Consciousness you're in
unity Consciousness so you don't have
the ego of going like
you don't have the subservient ego of
I'm below and you don't have the you
know um
the over the the superior ego of like I
am I meant I'm everything so it because
it's Unity Consciousness and so it's the
integrated ego and the integrated ego
understands that they're the ambassador
of source
and so that fifth dimensional
Consciousness understands inherently
just a part of that Consciousness is to
be out of Separation Consciousness and
into Unity Consciousness because of that
it's heart centered because how could
you be in unity
and still inflict pain yeah because it's
you
exactly does that person that you are
inflicting pain on is you you couldn't
do it
and that's why we really want certain
experiences to happen to timelines here
on Earth and those really great
experiences are utterly dependent on
Divine timing and divine timing is not
any date on a calendar
Divine timing is hey do you know that
you're the other because
how in the celestial jungle who wants to
allow you out into the great Wild
if we don't have like the most grounded
like integrated embodied perception
we're in a collective experience and yet
at the same time
the Shamanism in me that we all have our
own unique path too you know and should
we have certain goals
and we are not coming from a place of
resistance we can have our own separate
path and that maybe not might not even
entail like oh we're all going to the
same place but what I talk about in my
channel is you know everyone's on the
same party bus
but I completely am aware of and I just
don't talk about the fact that there are
certain people who have taken their
chakras out because they're going
someplace else I have nothing against
that
nobody I know who's not taken their
chakras out is you know a neophyte
they're not a newbie they this isn't
their first rodeo they know what they're
doing so for me I'm about the collective
experience and so I call that Ascension
Ascension is when we're all you know
going to the same place on the party bus
but we are we are we're all going the
same place well everyone who agrees to
that but that's why I made such a that's
why I really Illustrated a difference
because when you ask what the next step
is I I want to definitely honor a
person's individual Free Will and unique
life path
mm-hmm is this where the 3D 5D new Earth
split comes in where people just choose
to stay in a different reality
it's an unconscious choice so one could
say
is it a choice but yeah right because
it's not conscious so it's like but
they're stuck and so then I would tell
me that they're also not something about
it they're not willing to see truth
either
absolutely yeah so that's where the
timelines go come some people
um I know in hermeticism
strongly believe that it does not work
that way I don't lose sleep it's fine
other people can have different points
of view however how I see it is it's
absolutely like a hundred percent a
timeline split
uh I don't want that to be I like all
beings
to be free I like them all to not be in
this state of unconsciousness but I also
at the same time understand that that's
you know enormously
codependent of me I feel like we can be
codependent together I got a little bit
of that of me yeah so I got the Savior
complex just like all the rest of us but
I I also know that you know people are
not all prepared they're not all
operating at the same level of accessing
their Soul's Essence their higher self's
Essence and they've got their own
Journey with their own grooves in it
energetically will they just be coming
back again to they won't even be coming
back to Earth okay so no because Earth
is ascending so they're gonna go I don't
even know it could be some other yeah
Planet well they'll just become some
other extraterrestrial of a lower
consciousness of a third dimensional
Consciousness in some other
Galaxy of reality and with a reality
with that reality yeah and that's why we
see a lot of our guides come through as
like not well-formed entities and we can
even accidentally like praise them or
Revere them as being like oh whoa
because you know because you're like
alien and it's like a lot of them came
from failed timelines
a lot of them came from yo don't go down
that path I'm here to warn you from the
future we went down the wrong path and I
know we could get subjective and say you
know philosophically there is no such
thing as wrong and I would agree I would
absolutely agree that all of it adds to
the experiment so there's no such thing
technically as failed however the
objective truth within that is also yeah
there's such a thing as having degraded
Pathways and higher pathways
how does entropy pay into play into all
this because essentially the universe is
in
a path of in in a in a time is basically
entropy is what yeah how did the
universe get created and is this some
sort of form of entropy and how does
that how does that affect us entropy is
the force so it's not like oh it's
Centric like like entropy is the means
that the Universe uses but it's going
getting going away from us like
essentially is going away from us into
into less and less organization less
order
unless you become The Alchemist you can
harness that same entropy you can
harness it but yes for the sake of
occultism to stay not on mine my higher
plane of existence now but um In
classical esoteric terminology entropy
is definitely the force of chaos and not
in the great way it's leading towards
involution which is the opposite of
evolution meaning that that expansion
isn't like the positive type of
expansion it's the expansion of
fragmentation so much fragmentation and
so how you were saying earlier about the
two different timelines you could look
at it as a split going on where One path
is of entropy and the other path is of
centropy
what part of alchemy
Alchemy is always to separate and
recombine
separate and recombine so I would like
Alchemy to all happen right here as I'm
watching it but I know that I'm a part
of a separation and a combination
because it's always refining so by the
time you're done separating and combine
combining back and forth something has
become so refined and that refinement
process loses a lot of the um other that
the heavier layers of it
so those heavier layers of the process
of separating
the impurities from whatever is left
with whatever is fit enough we could
look at it fit enough to survive
would be that
um that excess that's being shedded off
through that cellular process of the
timeline split what part of me is in a
timeline in another timeline what part
of me splits like what is that I I guess
I I'm I only have my own little level of
Consciousness so I I'm trying to
visualize and oh your ego comprehend how
this happens so when a timeline splits
and there's me that goes off into I'm
assuming me that splits off into one
trajectory of of a reality of a timeline
of entropy perhaps then what is that
what what what is the me I guess let me
expand extend a little bit further when
I was
on that Hero's dose of psilocybin
Baseline reality was in it was a
waveform I was just like a stream and so
I'm wondering like does my stream split
what happens when there's a timeline
split your build up to that was way
funner than my response is going to be
it's okay because the the separating and
the recombining in this case when we're
talking about a large timeline split
like ascension-based timeline split is
one where the people headed towards
entropy or Unity Consciousness such as
yourself in that example will be
splitting and recombining
their own psyche so what is the shedding
or the die off would be
um levels of Illusion of ego but someone
else's would be shedding and fragmenting
into entropy one part of me is heading
towards
more order
where someone else might be just
splitting off to two two Pathways of
entropy four ten how much cognitive
dissonance can a person hold if a
woodchuck could chuck wood I it's it's
consolidating our cognitive dissonance
now once you clean up all of your
dissonance you won't exist
so this isn't about I know I know that's
what I saw
that's what I saw I saw I literally was
in that waveform and I was like I have
no idea how I'm going to be human again
I don't know because I know it's not
real
yeah
exactly so that's the level of
integration you're like writing the
waves and you know timelines and the
splitting and the recombining so you're
you're on your
dharmic alchemical Journey
um when it comes to that same process of
splitting and recombining going in the
level going in the opposite direction
the direction of unconsciousness
we're talking about maximum
fragmentation that can look like
that could look like severe levels of
cognitive dissonance
severe cognitive dissonance like a
person might agree with you
and then as soon as somebody comes in
the room
they'll switch into a new character in
their head and they're not like trying
to do any of this but let's say you're
talking about something and it's a
little woo or it's a little far out
there and then someone else comes into
the room this person can completely
switch into a different train track in
their head which is what the cognitive
dissonance is and this new character or
this new persona within them completely
real they're not making any of this up
doesn't agree with you at all they could
even be scoffing or they could even you
know like be where once there was a
little bit of Harmony now there's like
complete conflict and this happens all
of the time when it comes to the
cognitive dissonance getting more and
more severe because that's what
unconsciousness does unconsciousness
doesn't know that the left hand is a
part of the right hand they don't even
they're not even aware that their
appendages on an entity
that's how severe the cognitive
dissonance can become
when you say that it makes me in
conflict and cognitive dissonance and
and
that whole mess it makes me wonder what
relationships are for what are like
intimate relationships for because those
seem like they bring out the most amount
of
trauma the most amount of disagreement
the most amount of challenge emotion
what is that what is that for in this
reality
yeah for evolution
[Music]
and I would add this is my own two cents
um God doesn't want to be lonely
I just want to be lonely I tapped into
that I know firsthand experience I was
terrified of the fact that it had awoken
to its own existence
and to be in relation with something is
an enormously
um not buffered but it's an enormously
connected state
versus the loneliness and the feeling of
Abandonment or desolate that comes from
not being in relation
I wrote a poem about this did you yeah I
I heard a whole poetry book after that
is that why in a Rel like in a
relationship I'm using myself as an
example I've never actually felt really
lonely alone I've only actually felt
lonely in a relationship and I wonder if
it's because
the rejection of
the unity like rejection of self
essentially since we're all from the
same like is that God not accepting
itself essentially like that is like the
most traumatic sort of
um situation to be in it's worse than
being alone because it's actually
rejection
or rejecting a part of someone
I wouldn't say necessarily that feeling
lonely in a relationship is God
rejecting itself I'd say that that's
God
um being too scared to go find another
reflection that accurately reflects God
clearer so our relationships needed in
this oh absolutely because relationships
are mirrors
so relationship it'd be really hard to
not desire a relationship because what
you're Desiring is evolution right so
okay so let's put into so there's a
situation a conflict comes up you and
your partner
what do you do then how do you move
through that yeah you move through a
conflict through intimacy which means
that you tell your partner
where your part of the conflict is with
this they tell you what their part of
the conflict is with that and then you
try to see if there can be resolution
from those two sides of the conflict
and so having that ability to be heard
and to be seen
being seen is our deepest wound not
being seen is our deepest Moon as a
species yeah it's the narcissistic
wounding
so we weren't seen and then we started
from that ground point it went like look
you're not seen okay go and then you go
through life and then everyone has their
own special unique Journey based off of
that they were not seen properly
and so even if you had a great life this
isn't this isn't just discriminated
against anyone's life so being seen
is that way with the intimacy that
you navigate conflict
and so if that can't happen like in an
example where there's just loneliness
that would already mean that the
conditions were that you weren't feeling
that you were truly seen
because that's the core human wound so
that tends to be where a lot of our
disharmony lonely frustration comes is
actually an aspect of us that doesn't
feel seen
correct one thousand percent
how do we like did everyone have people
who went like oh my God you're like so
special you're like like no we everyone
had things projected onto them hopes and
fears
what is it that's perhaps
you know the most occult information
that would help Humanity evolve into
more of it more Unity Consciousness and
5D reality I'm going to be responsible
here I'm going to speak on behalf of my
oversoul
if you were irresponsible that's okay
too
the universe really wants us to
understand natural law
and natural law is pretty basic it's
the most occult information and what I
mean by that is all occult Traditions
had this as their end-all Beal meaning
they started with this and you ended
with this
it's even known that there's nothing new
Under the Sun
and when a person is talking about that
like what do you mean there's nothing
new Under the Sun what that's referring
to in occult terminology is natural law
meaning hey guess what's not going to
change in this universe at least with
our Hardware in this universe natural
law is not going to change and so since
your question was the most occult
information it could give for evolution
it would be that natural law is
completely binding meaning that
regardless of whether we're aware of it
or not it's at work
so even if we're not aware of it it's
still applying to us and what that is is
that there's
the non-aggression principle but also
the principle of force meaning that
don't start nothing don't violate
anybody but if somebody violates you you
have to do something
you have you have to protect someone or
yourself you have to use Force you
didn't want to but it came to you
but unless you're being violated or a
person's being violated if you don't
have to use Force there's the
non-aggression principle which is to do
not violate another being
and if I had to sum up evolution in a
nutshell which is you know like
not very mystical but believe it or not
this is like I'm not kidding this is the
most dense
nutrient dense occult information one
could give this is like
right there with the quadrivium
and so what Humanity needs to understand
is is that we're also complicit for our
non-action at a micro level and at a
macro level meaning that
how the universe is gauging how fit we
are as a species
how responsible we are
and there's severe consequences if we
don't meet this criteria is
hey do you take conscious actions
because what I just described was
conscious action
conscious action for oneself and
conscious action to make sure that a
person isn't violating another being
and if we don't meet that bare minimum
criteria for being able to understand
natural law and to live by natural law
how are we a fit species how are like
you even if a being didn't want to
become enlightened if you lived by that
standard you would become highly
enlightened on accident
because that's kind of like
that's the gauge that's like the litmus
test
where everything after that is like okay
they're fit okay they you know like
yeah if you protect yourself and you
protect someone else that needs
protection then that qualifies as a high
level of Fitness to be to sustain as a
species yes so that and we could just
spread this out to you know really broad
levels we could look at something where
if we're not immediately at that scene
of injury
if we're able to understand objective
reality to the best of our ability we
can be the better observer in that you
know car scene accident yeah without
doing so we can take conscious actions
meaning that if we just sit there and we
don't give our report that we are
actually from the from the universe's
standards not mine the universe says
you're 100 complicit
you might as well have done the evil
action
and it's not because
yeah it's not because the universe
doesn't understand
proximity or it doesn't understand you
know gray zones it's because
that's not a fit being
it's not an enlightened being what does
this mean for let's say activism or a
platform are you do you have to use it
or do you have to be part of activism or
movements or
you know your level of consciousness of
Truth like do you have to promote that
if you can
because one person's Dharma will be
different from another person's so they
don't have to do ground Roots activism a
lot of the ground Roots activism is 100
controlled opposition
so it's not about you know
I think activism serves a very important
purpose for our healing Journey it's
kind of like where we
practice where we get to exercise our
catharsis where we get to take back our
power but even that level of
the playing field of consciousness
is not the end-all be all so it's
activism but a spiritual activism at
wherever that person's capacity of
Consciousness is so at one point in time
I was
um like a regional coordinator I was a
volunteer to go get people's signatures
for against human trafficking in
California
that was at my time my Consciousness
believed in the system and you know and
that was my duty that was my Dharma
mm-hmm
but as a being continues to evolve
continues to awaken whatever that nature
is so everyone's nature won't look the
same somebody's activism will look
different and so it's our job now to
recognize our differences rather than
judge somebody's activism okay because I
I get stuck in this sort of like little
bit of a mental argument about which I
have my perspective which is I try I
really don't like to play into
movements or drama or politics I just
don't like I'd rather I think sometimes
the more you talk about like identity
Politics the more you talk about being
different and more you talk about the
problems that you want fixed the more
you're talking about the problems and so
for me it feels more in alignment to
just live the way I want to live and
talk about things that are moving in a
positive fashion and things that are
more optimistic than negative and sort
of this agreements more about like this
conversation how do we live like what
are the rules I just want to know so is
that acceptable within the laws law of
the universe to have to act if you see
like am I am I in violation in any way
by not using my voice to talk about XYZ
because I can the first level of reality
you were addressing is far different
from universal laws level of reality so
the first level of reality that you're
addressing about the system whatever
they're talking about with peace and
love it doesn't matter they're in
cognitive dissonance they're in complete
utter entropy cognitive dissonance I
agree so what so your activism
would be
the life you're living but then also
you I mean you have a large platform
where you're allowing people to expand
their Consciousness and then reconfigure
it and then expand their Consciousness
so you're leading people to sovereignty
which is a thousand percent what
universal law wants universal law is
universal law is about a being being in
their sovereignty when a being is in
their sovereignty maybe they'll agree
with you maybe they won't but it's
coming from their own
awakened State not the unconscious
program State you know back to the two
Natures
but they have that they have that unique
subjective reality of agreeing or
disagreeing but we all operate under
natural law under one objective reality
which is yeah we might agree or disagree
but we're not going to harm each other
we're not going to violate each other
and if that does happen we do something
we take conscious action so you have
once again the objective reality in this
universal law higher level of living
knowing that
also at the same time there's the fact
that as a sovereign being you're not
always going to agree
because you're not at the same place
yeah so you're doing high level
spiritual activism
I have like a jillion questions I think
this is like episode one of of many for
us but um I think that's good for today
I think that's a lot of great
information and a lot of activation as
planting seeds is really what I like to
do with the show
um
you know sometimes the first time people
hear things they're like what but then
the second time they hear them they're
like hmm
so if it's the first time I'm excited
for that because it's part of the
process
so absolutely I had so much fun thank
you yeah me too thank you like I just am
super grateful I just love your content
and
um you know I just so deeply appreciate
and gravitate towards people that are
able to articulate things in such a
clear way the way you are and there's a
saying it's if you don't understand I'm
not gonna it's paraphrasing basically
that if you don't understand something
well enough you can't explain it simply
and you just really understand things
quite simply for how complicated and
deep they are so
thank you thank you for living in your
Dharma I really appreciate that
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button